there are many unique techniques in the
jiujitsu Kaizen world but the domain
expansions are by far the strongest ones
these barrier techniques are considered
to be the Pinnacle of jiujitsu and only
the most skilled Sorcerers can perform
them currently in the show there are 12
different domains and in this video
we'll be explaining and ranking each one
for example joo's domain expansion is
called coffin of the Iron Mountain which
fits his appearance and curse technique
quite well this domain looks pretty much
like an active volcano with the
environment so hot that an average s
would die in seconds with this domain
Jugo utilizes a guaranteed hit to attack
his opponents with molten rocks this
pretty much means that Jug's attack will
always hit his Target no matter what
although this domain seems incredibly
powerful we never got to see its full
potential as it was quickly suppressed
by Gojo in his domain and later on in
joo's battle against sucon he didn't
even bother to activate it since he knew
it would just be suppressed Again by
sua's domain all in all coffin of the
Iron Mountain is a really strong domain
expansion and if joo's opponents weren't
the two strongest guys in the whole
series I'm sure he would show us his
full power this was only the first out
of 12 insane domains we'll cover in this
video and let's continue with Chimera
Shadow Garden Chimera Shadow Garden is
cast by mumi fushiguro and is the only
incomplete domain on this list we'll
talk about what that means a bit later
as the domain extends it entirely floods
the whole area with shadows which goes
perfectly with mum's curse technique the
tent Shadows it's really dark inside the
domain and there's a strange structure
that resembles the spinal bone with
nerves casting this domain dramatically
amplifies mum's 10 Shadows technique by
120% and also allows him to create
clones of himself from the Shadows
another feature of this domain is that
mum's opponents have to constantly
reinforce their footing with cursed
energy otherwise they'll be sucked in
Falling In the Shadow is like falling
into an abyss there's no Oxygen or
resistance making the target fall
indefinitely now since mum's domain is
still incomplete it doesn't have the
sure hit effect other domains do
moreover it also lacks a barrier as mumi
skill level is not high enough to
produce effective barriers and close his
domain however the most interesting
thing about this incomplete domain is
this bone we mentioned earlier as it may
hide one big secret currently these look
like two bones of the vertebrae and this
is why a lot of fans believe that this
bone will keep expanding as mumi becomes
stronger and eventually grow into some
kind of creature this is only a theory
for now but you have to admit that it
would be so cool if it actually happened
anyway although this domain seems pretty
strong it has one huge weakness you see
mumi is able to stuff in his Shadows
like weapons and shikigami but he must
bear their weight so if mum's opponent
manages to drop heavy objects into the
Shadows it would quickly crush him due
to this I think B tier is a Fitting
Place for it but domains don't always
have to be this complicated in order to
be deadly as we saw with Yu's domain
called three-fold Affliction this domain
is pretty much an empty space with some
insect-like appendages floating within
but what does it do well inside it all
of the objects yosu creates using her
curse techniques are guaranteed to hit
her Target which is especially deadly
when paired with Yu's ultimate technique
perfect sphere as the name suggests this
is well it's a perfect sphere which
generates infinite pressure and is
pretty much impossible to counter using
the combination of her domain and sphere
she can on-shot almost any Enemy No
matter how strong they are now I did say
almost as sua managed to counter the
domain and cut the sphere using mahara I
mean of course he did but if anyone else
was trapped inside it it's more or less
game over for them and we can't talk
talk about domain expansions without
mentioning the strongest sorcerer in the
current ERA Gojo satu in his insane
unlimited void as soon as this domain is
cast Gojo's targets are sent to an empty
space-like environment there Gojo can
use his Limitless technique to feed his
targets with infinite knowledge flooding
their brains with raw information to the
point they can no longer move or process
what's happening basically the target
can feel everything and nothing at the
same time in addition to completely
stunning opponents this domain can also
kill anyone if they stay in it for long
enough even Nami mentions how powerful
Gojo's technique is as it's a sure kill
once the target is trapped by it so how
long does it take for someone to die in
Gojo's domain well for normal humans
that number is a bit over 0.2 seconds
and for stronger curses it's probably
around a minute although it was never
specifically mentioned of course Gojo is
not affected by the unlimited void and
whoever he's holding or touching will
also be safe from it he can also very
accurately control the time the domain
will be open for it strengthen the
domain's barriers to protect it from
outside attacks and even decrease its
size to that out of a basketball but
this is most likely because of Gojo's
skill and has nothing to do with an
actual domain it goes without saying
that the unlimited void goes into the S
tier however not all domains send you to
a scary looking environment some of them
literally send you to a relaxing Sunny
Beach dagon's Horizon of the captivating
scanda is one of the first domains we
saw in the series and it's the place
Kaku and the curses used to relax during
season 1 but is coming as it may seem
this domain can be deadly if Dagon wants
it to be similar to other domains The
Horizon of the the captivating sconda
has the sure hit effect and uses many
different shiky gamis Dagon created to
attack the opponents the interesting
thing about this domain is that these
Shiki gamis appear very suddenly as they
practically don't exist till they hit
the target this makes it really hard to
block these attacks and once the Shiki
gami hits the target they Devour the
flesh immediately now an average
sorcerer will not be able to handle the
shikigami at all due to their incredible
speed however a higher grade sorcerer
can handle it we've seen this when Nito
a special grade one sorcerer was able to
block incoming attacks using his
techniques and later on toi made a joke
out of the domain blocking every single
attack and ultimately defeating Dagon so
while this domain is quite powerful it's
nowhere close to the strength of the
domains we're going to talk about soon
self- embodiment of perfection self-
embodiment of perfection is mjo's domain
and is one of the most unique domains in
the whole series miito deploys The
Domain by opening his mouth showing tiny
hands inside which then conjure specific
hand seals the environment inside is
filled with darkness and the hands
formed are gripped together like a
flower okay that that's pretty scary but
what does it do well mjo's curse
technique allows him to reshape the soul
of anyone he touches and in his domain
mahito is guaranteed to touch his Target
however although this sounds like a
great thing for mjo it can seriously
backfire you see when this domain is
cast mjo doesn't have a choice anymore
about who he wants to touch and has to
touch everyone inside it this is why
when Yuji broke the barrier and entered
the domain mjo was forced to touch his
and sua's soul which didn't end really
well for him later on in the story mjo
got much better at expanding his domain
being able to cast it only for 0.2
seconds same as Gojo now although
getting stuck at mjo's domain pretty
much means certain death there are some
ways to counter it for example if the
user is skilled enough like mechamaru
was they can protect themselves from
mjo's Idol Transfiguration by using
simple domain which acts as a barrier to
protect the target from the domain's
effect there are still six incredible
domains left to cover and two of them
are actually s tier domains time cell
Moon Palace aside from being really
complicated this domain also gets an
award for having by far the most
disturbing design anyway the user of
this domain is naoya zenim the youngest
son of naido as he expands his domain a
dark empty space immediately appears and
at the center is a path made of Flesh
that leads to a huge eye which sees
everything the targets inside the domain
are immediately injected with films of
Animation in their neck pretty weird I
know but bear with me afterward in order
to move inside the domain the target
must abide by the domain's 24 FPS rule
but what does that mean well according
to the 24 FPS rule the target cannot
walk normally from point A to point B
and instead has to move in frames to
better explain this imagine you have to
cover a distance of 24 M you would
normally walk or run to that spot
without any delay however if you do that
in Nya's domain you will surely regret
it so in order to avoid the domain's
punishment you have to actually hop
across in 1 M chunks stop it each spot
for precisely 1 124th of a second and
then hop to the next meter and so on ens
short you need to move like an anime
animation frame by frame those who don't
understand the 24 FPS rule mostly end up
making the wrong movement without
realizing it when this happens the
targets can suffer numerous injuries on
their bodies get Frozen for one second
or if they try to force a movement
against the rules their limbs will get
cut off as you can imagine it's near
impossible to dodge attacks in this
domain as you have to be mindful of your
movements at all times and even one
wrong step or off timing can be
devastating the only reason naoya lost
at the end was because he was unable to
track mak's movements due to her having
no cursed energy but if it was anyone
else trapped inside it they would have
almost 0% chance of surviving but let's
move from a complicated domain to a
rather simple one the graveyard domain
cast by the small pox deity now although
this domain is simple it shouldn't be
underestimated as it can kill its Target
within 3 seconds the small boox D uses
certain hand signs to activate this
domain and as soon as it's activated it
traps the target inside a coffin
afterward the curse drops a massive
gravestone Stone on top of the coffin
dealing considerable damage to the
Target inside and burying them
underground once the target is
underground the cursed Spirit counts to
three and within 3 seconds the target
has to break out of the gravestone
otherwise they'll die however if the
target manages to free themselves
they're still not in the clear as
they'll immediately get trapped again
repeating the whole process overall the
graveyard domain is a pretty annoying
one but considering the low intelligence
level of the special grade curse casting
it it wasn't that hard for mayay and oui
to distract it and eventually escaped
the domain womb profusion kinjaku is the
main villain of the Jujutsu Kaizen and
is an incredibly strong character who
has been preparing his plan for ages his
domain expansion also doesn't disappoint
as it has one Divine ability not even
Gojo's domain has as soon as womb
profusion is cast a bunch of cursed
Spirits faces merg together to form a
creepy looking Tower although we know
very little about this domain it seems
that as soon as a Target gets close to
the tower they get hit by a massive
force that is as powerful as ghetto
maximum Uzumaki which is well pretty
damn powerful the first time we saw
kaku's domain was in a battle against
Yuki and although it was only open for
less than 10 seconds it was enough to
mortally injure Yuki a special grade
sorcerer and almost kill her it's not
fully clear exactly what strikes the
targets inside kaku's domain but it
seems that they're struck by gravity
itself which would make sense
considering kaku's gravity abilities but
what makes this domain truly powerful is
the fact that it doesn't have any
barriers around it and instead covers
the whole area around kinjaku it's also
important to mention that simple domains
like the one mechamato used to counter
bejito don't work in this domain and are
quickly dispelled leaving the target
completely defenseless considering that
Kaku managed to defeat a special great
sorcerer within a few seconds of casting
womb profusion it obviously deserves to
go into s tier okay all the domains so
far were about increasing the strength
and power of the characters I mean isn't
that the whole point well yeah but there
is one domain that does none of that and
it's called deadly sentencing this
domain is cast by hiromi Hig and looks a
lot like a courtroom although the domain
is non-lethal it's much more detailed
compared to other domains inside it homi
and the target stand across each other
and play the roles of the prosecutor and
defendant they pretty much undergo a
trial and every form of violence is
completely restricted inside the domain
therefore instead of having a surhe head
attack like other domains deadly
sentencing forces the target inside to
follow hiromi's rules now as soon as the
domain is cast the trial starts and a
shiky gummy called judg man appears
acting as the judge he immediately
shares the charges against the defendant
which is usually the crime they
committed in the past for example in
yuji's case he was accused of playing
slot machines while being under rage the
defendant then has to prove themselves
innocent and can even lie if they want
to the only thing they have to do is
convince the judg man that they're
innocent Yuji did this by saying that he
only used the toilet in the gambling
house and didn't play any betting games
in there after this is done hodama has
one chance to prove that the defendant
is lying and he can do this with the
help of evidence judge man gives him
once both hodama and the defendant are
done explaining the judg man gives the
final verdict if the defendant is guilty
the most common sentence is confiscation
which stops them from using their curse
technique for the rest of the fight
however the defendant can also be
charged with a death sentence and if
that happens homi gets the Executioner
sword which can kill the Target in a
single cut overall it's a pretty complex
domain but considering how it doesn't
really attempt to kill the Target and
usually only restricts them in some way
I can't place it any higher than C tier
before we cover the absolutely strongest
domain on this list let's first cover
the most unique one it's called the idle
death Gamble and it's cast by kinji
hakati a third-year student at Tokyo
jiujitsu high this domain basically
takes inspiration from a popular
Japanese arcade game called Pachinko and
the overall theme of The Domain is based
on romance manga series called private
pure love train to simplify it hak's
domain expansion is pretty much a slot
game with manga characters this is the
only domain in the series that doesn't
Grant the user any immediate advantages
instead it heavily relies on luck and
hakati has to hit the jackpot in order
to get on massive power up before we
explain what this power up is let's
first see how this jackpot thing even
works you see in hak's domain there's
only a 1 in 239 chance of hitting the
jackpot based on this you may think that
hak's domain is not that powerful as
it's really hard to get a power up but
you're forgetting one important thing
hakati is extremely lucky even to the
point that the domain seems rigged in
his favor also the important thing to
mention is that the more jackpots hakati
hits the higher the chance he has of
hitting another jackpot meaning that
once he starts his winning streak his
opponent is practically screwed so what
happens to hakati when he hits the
jackpot well first of all he gets the
unlimited amount of cursed energy and in
addition to that all of the damage he
suffers is immediately healed making him
Unstoppable these powered boosts last
for exactly 4 minutes and 11 seconds and
during that time a theme song from
private pure love train is playing the
only thing more interesting than this
domain is hak's dance after he hits the
jackpot that alone makes his domain
worthy of a tier and now let's cover the
domain you've all been waiting for SU
malevolent Shrine considering sua's
strength it goes without saying that
this is one of the strongest domains in
the entire jiujitsu Kaizen malevolent
Shrine looks pretty much like a regular
Buddhist Shrine but has been distorted
to look more demonic and evil with a
giant mouth at the entrance and several
bull-shaped skulls similar to other
domains malevolent Shrine has a
guaranteed hit effect making sua's
techniques cleave and dismantle always
hit their target once the domain is open
these two techniques repeatedly slash
anyone inside until nothing remains
except SU himself same as kaku's domain
malevolent Shrine doesn't have barriers
meaning everyone in suk's proximity is
affected but if there aren't any
barriers doesn't that mean that sua's
opponents can just Escape well yeah but
it's not that simple as sua can extend
his domain up to 200 M making it pretty
much impossible for anyone to leave
without being killed first since the
domain doesn't have any barriers it also
means that it can't be destroyed from
the outside so how does someone counter
this domain well it's pretty much
impossible
in theory the only way would be to
damage sua enough to the point that he's
unable to maintain it and yeah nobody in
the show is strong enough to do that but
if you ever wondered how sukuna became
such a powerful Sorcerer And why no one
will ever be as strong as him click on
this video next where we explain all
sua's powers in jiujitsu Kaizen